[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
thursday july 21st i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
for the last two years it's been good to
be a food delivery company demand was
high as people stayed home and revenue
rose with more restaurants and customers
signing up but as the economy slows and
inflation soars the best of times may be
over for some delivery giants according
to market research firm yipit data the
total number of orders for food delivery
companies in the second quarter of this
year grew up by 11
but that's a big drop from the 88 growth
they experienced during the same period
in 2020
so how do these companies plan to
grapple with the first major slowdown in
their short histories
and what can they do to convince
investors they're still on solid ground
joining us to discuss this is our geek
market reporter preetik arana hi pritika
nice to have you back on the show great
to be back on the show
so these food delivery apps are still
growing they're just growing more slowly
so what are companies like doordash and
ubereats doing to keep customers
spending money
right so they have rolled out a host of
measures this year one is just they're
sweetening the deal
to try to convince customers to become
subscribers now subscribers pay a
monthly fee but they enjoy
discounts on food they enjoy no delivery
fees and from the company's perspective
subscribers actually spend a lot more
than non-subscribers
and they have higher order values so
it's in their best interest to get as
many customers to become subscribers and
then what the apps are also doing is
they're tweaking their apps to trigger
more spending and moving beyond food to
give people more reasons to return so
you know you can now order everything
from toothpaste to toilet paper to your
groceries to flowers even a thanksgiving
turkey
on you know doordash and ubereats and as
far as restaurants are concerned they're
negotiating deals to keep them from
increasing delivery prices so doordash
negotiated a deal with mcdonald's where
they can't raise delivery prices
more than 30 percent of what the
in-store prices and at the same time
they're also diversifying beyond
delivery and offering new services to
restaurants they've started giving
restaurants that have a history of good
sales on the app they've started giving
them loans they've also started
investing in in-store technology for
restaurants so you know how we all got
used to scanning the qr code at
restaurants you know doordash recently
bought a company that lets you scan the
qr code and it lets you order food and
pay for your food on your cell phone so
what torah is essentially doing is for
understaffed restaurants it's saying hey
use this technology and better manage
your stuff
is that helping with some of the
complaints that we heard from
restaurants earlier in the pandemic i
mean they're having their costs rise
with inflation and a lot of them had
raised concerns about huge demand from
delivery making it difficult to run
their restaurants so how are they
reacting to these delivery apps kind of
stepping in
some of the big chains are investing in
behind their own delivery um network and
their own delivery apps so this way they
don't have to be a commission on every
order you know restaurants get all the
consumer data as opposed to the apps but
i think
both restaurants and delivery apps
need each other you know it's it's a
give and take right you need something
to deliver in the end i wonder how
analysts and investors are reading into
you know both the slowdown and the
efforts that these delivery companies
are making to address the slowdown it's
a tough time for these companies
analysts and investors are definitely
worried remember these apps are
relatively
new
the food delivery industry hasn't faced
a recession so the big question that
analysts are asking is do consumers
start
treating food delivery as a necessity or
as a luxury when the times turn and that
question remains to be answered there
are some early signs that in places
outside the us you know the uk's
delivery
recently slashed its full year guidance
they said you know we're facing
consumer headwinds
and we don't think they're going to be
spending as much as we thought they
would be so early signs are definitely
pointing to a pullback
so we've talked about doordash and
ubereats what about the third biggest
player in this market grubhub how is it
faring
well grubhub is in the midst of a big
reckoning so
in many ways grubhub pioneered this
industry you know they weren't doing
delivery back in the day you know they
started with online orders and
restaurants would fulfill the deliveries
on their own on their end but uber and
doras quickly came in and decimated that
model with gig workers doing deliveries
they had a lot of venture capital money
so they quickly ate up the food delivery
market and it's startling before the
pandemic grubhub had 21 market share
now it's fallen to some 10
so grubhub's parent company which only
bought it a year ago
is looking to sell the company again
just given the competitive pressure now
unlike doordash and uber which still
managed to grow in the first quarter
compared to last year even though it was
it's slowing growth
grubhub's orders actually fell so
grubhub is looking at ways to
turbocharge growth and one of the ways
in which they are doing this is that
earlier this year they inked a
partnership with amazon where all of you
know amazon prime's more than 200
million subscribers are gonna get
grubhub plus which is their sort of you
know monthly subscription for free and
it might help them take back some of
that market share that they've lost all
right i guess we'll just have to see how
this plays out that's our reporter
preetik arana thanks for joining us
preetika thank you so much
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website
wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you